- Hi FriDiary!
Welcome.
Sometimes its not on you.
- Well, you're holding it like it.
- Hello, welcome to Fridiary.
Now it's SaturDiary 'cause it's Saturday
and I didn't uploaded this last night.
I'm sorry, I got sleepy.
If you did not know,
FriDiary is a lookback
at my weekend vlog forum,
so let's look back at some of the stuff
that's happened this week.
- You ready?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- This is really a periscope
type of activity, so...
- You know what?
You know Snapchat.
All I need is ten seconds.
- [Voiceover] Oh man, I got no life
and it's all on you guys.
- [Voiceover] This is basically
a pineapple smoking a blunt.
- There you go.
- It is.
Pineapple Express.
- Let me do one of your segways.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- And then this happened!
- [Voicover] Maybe you broke
it 'cause you went so fast.
You broke it 'cause it went so fast!
- It gave no information
of anything we want.
- [Voicover] You broke it
'cause it went so fast. So fast.
(Mexican Mariachi music)
- [Voicover] So, what did you get?
- [Voiceover] He got 50.
- [Voicover] No, you did not.
- Uh oh. Oh no!
(Mexican Mariachi music)
- Dirty rhythm, that's that dirty rhythm!
- God, oh my God!
He's Killing us!
- I got like a 100 so
it's like not a big deal.
(cheering)
- I've scored a tie that's a 90--
(slow melancholic music)
(inaudible dialogue)
(Cover of "Under Pressure" by Queen)
(Cover of "Total Eclipse of
the Heart" by Bonnie Tyler)
(Cover of "Hello"by Lionel Richie)
(Cover of "It's All Coming
Back to Me Now" by Celine Dion)
- [Voiceover] She could hit that note.
- [Voiceover] Oh no, oh girl.
(upbeat rock music)
- And then this happened.
(goofy music)
And then this happened.
(electronic music)
- And now I'm at the
greatest place on earth
the Airport, about to head to New York
with this one.
We're headed to New York, I'm going
for a day, two days.
We're gonna go see Kinky Boots
with Wayne Brady, it's very exciting.
- Wayne Brady!
- Yeah, that's the actual
way you pronounce his name.
If you haven't RSPV'd to
dirty30movie.com yet, you should.
Also, if you haven't bought your tickets
for one of our no-filter shows
in Australia yet, you should.
And if you haven't
pre-ordered "Grace and Styled:
The Art of Pretending
You Have It" my new book,
a tongue in cheek style
guide yet, you should.
And enter the sweepstakes.
I don't know.
(Cover of "End of the
Road" by Boyz II Men)